This semester, we are going to analyze a
question together, which is how do
societies behave?
Why do we do what we do?
What motivates us?
What drives us?
And there have been different theories
as to what drives human behavior. Okay,
so let's go over some
theories.
The first theory
comes to us
from
um religion.
And the idea is that
we are all driven
in a war between good
and evil.
There's a good side to us and there is
an evil side to us. There's Satan and
there's God.
And we
are caught in a battle
in ourselves.
Okay? Do we move towards Satan or do we
move towards God? And that's the core of
human civilization. So religion is meant
to give us the strength, to show us the
path towards goodness. Okay, that's one
theory.
Another theory
is
comes to us from biology.
Okay, and the idea is
sex.
We want to pass on our genes
forward because that's the point of our
existence.
If we cannot have children, we all die.
So the point of existence
is to
have children and have them pass on
their genes to others, okay?
And
for males and females
life is different because as a man you
have a penis.
And all you have to do is stick your
penis into a woman and you're good.
Okay, that's all you have to do.
So you want to stick your penis in as
many women as possible and that's the
point of your existence.
But as a woman, your life is different
because
it's hard to give birth.
It takes 9 months to incubate the child
in your womb and then pit childbirth is
the most painful experience
anyone will ever experience. And then
the child, it'll take like 16 18 years
to raise a child to maturity. So there's
a huge investment on your part. So as a
female
you have to be very cautious,
very careful about who you marry or you
have or you or you or who you have sex
with, okay? And so life is a struggle
between men who want to put their penis
in into anything and women who want to
be careful about who they marry. Okay?
So that's the idea of biology.
Then of course you have the idea of race
and culture.
That the world it's a struggle between
these different races and cultures for
dominance. And each race, each culture
has their own characteristics.
Okay, so maybe the yellow race, it's
they're very clever
but they're very weak.
And then the white races are brave but
kind of stupid. And the black people
like anyway. Anyway, that's another
theory. I'm not saying it's correct, I'm
just saying it's a theory that people
believe in.
Then you have economics.
Right? And what they believe is that we
are driven by money or self-interest.
We want to make as much money as
possible
and that's what drives us.
Okay? That's pretty simple.
And the last big theory is the idea of
liberalism
that comes from the enlightenment.
And here the theory is that history is a
progress
towards enlightenment, to rationality,
to truth and to justice. So the
inevitability of history, of human
development is towards paradise, towards
heaven. And maybe, you know, we go off
track now and then, but inevitably we
move towards God. And this comes to us
from the enlightenment. We call this
liberalism. Okay, so these are five
theories, there are others, but these
are five theories that show you the
diversity,
the variety of ideas out there.
What I will do this semester is present
to you another theory,
which I call game theory.
>> [snorts]
>> And my argument to you is that game
theory is the best way to understand how
humans behave. What drives nations,
what drives societies,
what drives humans. Okay? So that's my
that's my argument to you this semester.
So the entire semester we will study
game theory.
All right, so what is game theory?
All right, game theory
is very simple.
The idea is that
there are three components to a game.
Just three
aspects to a game. There are the
players,
the participants.
Okay?
Then there are the rules
or the constraints.
Um in mathematics we would call this the
boundary conditions, okay? The limits to
the game.
And the third aspect are the incentives.
Basically, how do you win this game?
What do you get from this game? And my
argument to you this semester is that if
you study all three, okay? If you got
who the If you figure out who the
players are, if you got who the If you
understand the rules, you understand the
incentives, then you understand how the
game works and then therefore you can
predict how the game will turn out.
Okay, that's the skill that I want to
teach you this semester.
And what I want to show you, what I
promise you is that
if you learn game theory,
there'll be three major benefits to you
as a student.
Again, you don't have to learn game
theory.
You don't have to You don't have to come
to class. But if you spend the effort
to learn game theory from me,
then three things will benefit you,
okay? The first benefit
is that you'll become a better person.
The point of education, guys, it's not
to get good grades or get in university
or get a good job. What I believe is the
point of education is to make you into a
better person, which means that you are
a much more thoughtful person
who can better analyze yourself and the
world around you.
This allows you to make better better
decisions. This makes you a much more
curious, much more moral and much more
imaginative person, okay? So one benefit
of learning game theory is you become
smarter and therefore you you become a
better person.
Okay? That's number one.
Um
number two is
you'll be able to understand
the world
that we live in because this world is
kind of stupid, okay? So you may have
heard that Donald Trump um and the
American military went into Venezuela
for no real for no good reason,
kidnapped a president of Venezuela,
which is against you which is against
national law and then brought him back
to New York City where he will stand
trial. It's really stupid what happened.
But then but our class it's not meant to
say this is stupid or this is wrong
because we all know it's stupid and
wrong. We're trying to figure out why
this happened
and what this will lead to.
And so we will be in this class studying
and analyzing current events to
understand how the world really works,
why people behave the way they they do
and understand how the game of the world
works. And this requires you to actually
follow the news.
Okay? It's not hard to spend 5 minutes
and just read up on the news. We'll be
looking at the the war in Ukraine. We'll
be looking at a new war between Israel
and Iran.
We'll be looking at what's happening in
South America. We'll be looking at the
conflict between
China and Japan.
We'll be looking at the relationship
between the United States and China,
okay? So this is relevant to your lives
because you'll be you will eventually
have to work and live in this really
screwed up world that we live in.
Okay?
And the third benefit
is
once you understand the game,
you will have predictive powers.
You'll be able to understand how the
world will evolve. You'll be able to
analyze your own life and understand how
you would evolve.
And that gives you
control,
sovereignty over your own destiny.
Okay? That's my promise to you. If you
actually spend the time to listen
carefully in class, to participate
fully, to follow the news,
uh and you spend the entire semester
doing so, then these three benefits will
start to accrue in you. Okay? This is a
lifelong struggle to learn game theory.
I'm a lot older than you are. I have a
lot more experience than you.
Okay? But I want to show you how to look
at the world through game theory.
Another phrase that you you learn in
school is, "I'm going to teach you how
to think critically
about the world."
Well, I'll just teach you how to think,
okay?
All right?
Are we clear?
Any questions
before I move on?
All right.
So, this is all very abstract.
And so, what I'm what I'm going to do
now is I'm going to use an example
of a game
to show you how game theory works, okay?
All right.
So, let's let's use a really simple
game, okay? Let's imagine there are five
boys and five girls.
And they want to get married.
Okay? So, these are the players.
And what we're going to do is we're
going to line up them up into male and
female.
Then what we're going to do is we will
rank
the males and the females.
Okay? So, we're going to rank 10 players
into five,
four,
three,
two, one.
Five, four, three,
two, one, okay? And so, how do we rank
them? Well, we rank them according to
their attractiveness using three
criteria.
Uh the first is genes.
The second is wealth.
And the third is status.
Okay? So, genes is very simple. It means
that you're good-looking.
It means you're tall. It means you're
healthy. You you will live a long time,
okay? Genes is pretty simple to
understand.
Wealth just means that you and your
family have a lot of money.
Status means that you have a lot of
friends. You have a high-status job.
You come from a really
powerful family, okay?
So, these are the three criteria that we
can use to judge a person's
attractiveness.
And then what we can do is rank them
from five to one. Five means really the
best. One means
the worst, okay? And we can rank all 10
uh according to these metrics.
So,
according to
biology, what we call evolutionary
biology or evolutionary psychology,
we're always trying to find the best
genes to procreate because this ensures
that our genes pass on.
Okay?
So,
um remember that men have a penis, which
they can stick into anything. Women have
to give birth, so their strategies are
different, okay? So, basically, five,
number five, is trying to have sex with
all
five women, right?
That's his strategy.
Um
Now, but female number five wants to
ensure that
she only gets five.
Okay? So, these are
different strategies.
And
uh
If this If according to evolutionary
psychology, all five of these females
should try to procreate
with number five, okay? But we know you
can't do this. It's suicidal.
Why is it suicidal? Because
the human race couldn't survive, right?
It'd be idiotic to do something like
this, where all five women are just
trying to marry this one guy. It may be
him, okay? But these three are
eliminated.
Because then your society would
collapse.
You wouldn't you could not have that
many children.
So, this can't possibly be true, right?
So, let's figure out what rationally
what should happen.
Okay?
All right.
So, let's think about this rationally.
>> [snorts]
>> Or from an economics perspective. All
right.
So, again, number five,
he's trying to maximize
the game.
So, he's trying to sleep with all five
women, okay?
The problem if he does that is
these five know they're all being
played.
And they recognize that this guy is
probably an So, five,
the best woman is like, "You know what?
There's not much of a difference between
four and five, so I'll just go marry
this guy."
Right? So, number four is gone.
And then number four is like, "You know
what?
Five is probably making a good decision,
so I'll just go marry number three."
Right?
And then
what happens now is that five, by trying
to
marry all the women, is stuck with the
worst choice.
Right?
So, that's kind of stupid for him. He's
stuck with number one.
But guess what? If any of these guys try
this crap, the same thing happens to
him, where four is like, "You know what?
I I can't get five, but I'll but I'll
try to get four and three together." And
then three is like, "Screw you. I'm
going to I'm going to go and marry two."
Four is going to marry three, okay? Then
he's stuck with one as well.
Or he's just alone.
So, if they try to individually
maximize their outcome, they all get
screwed in the end. So, the only way out
out of this
is that they cooperate, okay? And the
best way to cooperate is basically five
is like, "You know what? Screw this. I'm
not going to go after four or three.
I'll just I'll just have number five,
okay?"
All right?
Four is like, "Yeah, I'll just go marry
four. No dating.
No games.
I'll just go marry four. And three
marries three, two marries two, and one
marries one, okay? And the world now is
perfect.
Everyone has a husband and a wife. And
they can now just have children, and the
world is perfect. And this is actually
the best
strategy
for all the players, right? We call this
The word in game theory we call we use
for this is called the Nash equilibrium.
Okay? Nash equilibrium just means that
you always reach a state in which all
the players maximize their outcome, the
Nash equilibrium.
And so, the world makes sense now.
There's a problem with this, though.
The problem is
in real life,
no one does this.
Okay? In real life,
no one actually follows this rule. Nash
equilibrium is just a theory we made up.
But in real life, that's just not what
happens.
What happens in real life is
we choose to be suicidal.
Okay?
So, let me tell you about a game I
played.
So, last year I was teaching this class,
and I asked the boys and I asked the
girls, "Pretend you're now 30 years old.
Right? Your parents are pressuring you
to get married.
And you've been on the dating market for
10 years. There's really no one that you
think is perfect for you. You've You've
You've have basically given up on love.
Imagine
that you want to get married now. And
tell me what is the minimum requirement
you need in order to agree to marry
someone else."
Okay? What's the minimum, okay?
And then I had the boys and the girls
write down their response.
The boys were pretty simple, right?
Well, you know, as long as she likes me,
and as long as I can put my penis into
her, I'm good, okay? It's that simple,
okay?
It really is. Guys are like,
"Yeah, I'll settle for anything."
That's the that's the boys, right?
Girls were different.
Girls were like, "Okay.
If I don't love him,
if I'm not even attracted to him, I need
about a million dollars a month."
Really? Oh my god. Yeah. I need about a
million dollars. Last class.
Last semester. Okay. All right. So,
>> [laughter]
>> this makes no sense, right? So, in
theory,
And this guy in theory, we should follow
the Nash equilibrium. But in real life,
what happens is this. All the girls want
this one guy.
Okay? It may be number four. Let's have
them for number four. But three, two,
one, they don't want.
And we know because just look at the
world around you. Look at these
billionaires, right? Like Elon Musk. How
many wives does does he have?
How many children does he have?
Right?
All the women in the world, many, not
all, but many just want to marry actors
like Brad Pitt.
Billionaires like Elon Musk.
Right?
And three, two, and one,
they What do they do? Well, they watch
Netflix, they watch porn, they play
video games. They give up on life, okay?
They're like, "We don't care."
We call these people incels, right?
Involuntary celibates because basically
they give up give up on life and life
has given up on them.
So, this entire competition is between
number five and four for all the women
in the world.
And this is
suicidal. This will lead to the death of
humanity.
And the question now is,
okay,
why are we suicidal?
And
so,
let's look at game theory analysis,
right? The players, the rules, and
incentives. We don't We know what the
players are. The players are doing
stupid things.
The rules we know, okay? But incentives
is something that we have to think
about. Why they behave like this? And
the answer is
because they're not interested in sex
or procreation.
What they're interested in is status.
Okay? That's the game they play, status.
I don't want to marry someone have
children. I don't marry someone so I can
take a picture of her and post it on
Instagram so I can get a lot of likes.
I want to marry someone so I can walk
with her in the mall and all the guys
are jealous.
I want to marry someone who I can brag
about.
Okay? It's It's a game about status, not
a game about sex or procreation. Do you
understand? They're not People are not
being rational here.
People are trying to maximize their
status in life. And that's why
everyone's behaving like this.
Number
She may be the ugliest woman in the
world, but she's still like, "You know
what? It's still my choice whether I
have kids. And having kids is a pain in
the ass."
So, if I'm If I'm going to make the
sacrifice, this guy better be
good-looking.
Okay? Or this guy better be rich.
Otherwise, why would I want to have
kids?
Okay?
So, this is why people behave the way
they do. If you think about this way,
what you recognize is that people are
rational.
But to understand why they're rational,
you have to figure out what the game is.
Okay?
But then this leads to us to a question,
which is, okay, well, clearly this is
wrong because if we behave like this
throughout human history, we wouldn't be
here today.
Okay? How is it that we have this game
today
and we're going to die, but we we must
have come from somewhere. We've been
around for like a long time. So, how is
it that humans have survived for so long
doing these stupid things?
And the answer is this a game changes
over time according to the
superstructure of society.
Okay, the superstructure.
The superstructure is what determines
the nature of the game. Superstructure,
just think about the big picture, right?
How many people are there?
Is the society wealthy or poor?
Are there enemies to the society? Okay?
This is the superstructure, the big
picture. Demographics, economics,
culture, politics, religion.
And these things together is what
determines the nature of the game.
All right, so let's look at three
examples of superstructure.
All right.
Um example one is you have a low
population
society, okay? Low population is like
maybe 200 people, 300 people, okay? A
village, basically.
They are poor.
And
um
low technology. Low technologies means
they don't have access to clean water.
They don't know what hygiene is. They
don't understand what germs are. So,
it's very easy for a woman to die in
childbirth.
Okay?
And um low competition.
Low competition just means that
there are no competing villages against
them.
Okay? So, that's one kind of
superstructure.
The earliest superstructure of human
society, okay?
Then you have maybe growing population.
Okay? So, maybe we're talking like maybe
10,000 people, 20,000 people.
They are now growing in wealth, growing
wealth.
Um they have some technology, meaning
they have access to clean water,
and they have high competition.
Okay?
Meaning that they're competing against
different villages and societies around
them.
Okay, that's another superstructure.
Now, the third superstructure is
overpopulation,
okay? Which is the world we live in
today, okay? Where in China you have a
billion people. That's a lot of people.
Um
too much wealth.
Okay? But with wealth you have
inequality, right?
And then you have high technology. This
high technology just means that every
woman who gives birth will not die. And
every child born will live on will live,
okay?
And then you have a something called an
equilibrium.
Equilibrium just means that yeah,
there's competition, but they're not
going to go to war against each other.
The world is basically peaceful.
Okay?
And according to superstructure,
the game is going to change.
So, let's go back to the game, okay? We
have
10 people.
In a low population poor society, guess
what? They're not going to date.
What they're going to do is they might
get married, but they're going to have
sex with each other.
Why? Because as a woman,
the only way to ensure that your child
survives is if all the men in the
village
want to
protect and nurture the child.
And they will do that if they believe
that the child could be theirs, okay?
So, the woman will maybe have a husband,
but the woman will also choose to sleep
with other men to disguise paternity.
Does that make sense? So, there's no
dating, there's just lots and lots of
sex in order to maintain social
political cohesion, okay?
Now, in a superstructure number two,
there's no dating either.
Why? Because this society is in
competition with other societies, and
they need to have as many children as
possible. So, what the the solution here
is to have arranged marriages.
Arranged marriages.
Where,
you know, who cares who you marry? Just
have lots and lots of kids, okay?
There's no dating either. Just have lots
and lots of kids. You marry who your
parents tell you to marry. You marry
someone that you know. You marry your
childhood best friend. Who cares, okay?
But you marry someone, you have lots and
lots of kids.
Okay? That's superstructure number two.
Superstructure number three is the one
we live in. And here you have a dating
game.
Right? Because why?
Because
the odds of you obtaining status is
really, really low, okay? And the only
way that you can change your status is
by marrying up.
>> [clears throat]
>> And that's why you have a dating game. A
dating game is opportunity for you to
find someone better than your social
demographic circumstance can suggest.
Okay?
And that's why you have
low
uh decreasing
uh fertility rate.
Okay? Where over time, because of the
dating game,
society will collapse.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right.
So, now you're the government,
and all around the world,
women who are wealthy, well-educated,
are refusing to have children,
especially in East Asia.
Right now, the fertility rate in China
is about one.
Okay? About one. The replacement rate
that you need is a 2.1. So, just to
maintain your current population levels,
every woman in China needs to give birth
to at least two
kids.
But right now, on average, women are
choosing to have one kid only in China.
And the worst thing is that this trend
is
increasing. So, five years ago, the
fertility rate was maybe 1.7.
Now it's one. Okay, so the trend is
very, very negative. Okay? So,
governments all around the world are
trying to figure out
what
to do.
How do you
convince
woman to have more kids?
And what we've discovered is
it's impossible.
We can pay you more money, like they do
in South Korea. Guess what? It doesn't
work.
Because people don't want money, they
want status. And status is a zero-sum
game.
Okay?
Money is infinite, but status, power, is
a zero-sum game.
So, we have overpopulation, we have too
many people competing for two status too
few status positions.
You have decreasing
fertility rate. And there's nothing you
can do about it. The moment you give
woman choice,
they choose to improve their lives by
marrying someone better.
Okay? Not all, but most. And so, over
time, what happens is your society
collapses.
If you look at history, the best
indicator that a society is about to
collapse is if the woman who are wealthy
and well-educated, if they refuse to
have children. This is the same This is
what happened to the Romans, who
collapsed. This is what happened um to
many empires. This is what's happening
around the world today, in America, in
Britain, in Europe, in China.
Okay? And this tells us that society is
collapsing. So, in other words,
what this really is, okay? These
superstructures,
it tells us
the life cycle of a civilization.
Right?
So, this is when you when civilization
is young,
then it mature, it grows,
and then it
collapses.
Okay?
And if you look at history, all
civilizations go through this process of
birth,
maturation, and then collapse.
And there's no way around it.
So, the power of game theory is that
just by studying one aspect, okay? If I
just start studying this game,
all right? I figure out who the players
are, the rules, and incentives, I figure
out what the superstructure
of the civilization is, okay? And then
once I have these two, I can now
figure out where it came from and where
it's going.
Okay?
That's what I want to teach you in this
class.
How to analyze a situation
so you understand the players, the
rules, and incentives, which will give
you insight into superstructure,
so that you can figure out where it came
from, and then you you can also predict
where it's going.
All right?
So, but you can also look at the
superstructure and figure out what the
game is being played.
Okay, so this is one example, but but
throughout the semester we'll be doing
many many
many different examples of game theory.
Is this clear so far?
Any questions?
Any comments, any questions before I
move on?
All right.
All right, so let's just look at some
basic
>> [clears throat]
>> facts.
Okay?
All right, so
All right, this is a map of the world,
okay?
As you can see, okay, uh sorry. So, the
color scheme is this.
The red
is where the population
uh the society has an above replacement
fertility rate, okay? So, above 2.1.
If it's dark red, like here in the
middle of Africa, it's six to seven, or
six above, okay? And why why is it that
the case? Because Africa is in this in
this situation where it's a growing
society with middling tech, so a lot of
people die, lots of competition, so to
survive, families have to give birth to
a lot of kids, okay? They have no choice
in the matter.
But then you move to the rest of the
world, okay? So, this is um North
America, Europe, and East Asia, the
three wealthiest parts of the world. And
guess what? The fertility rate is
collapsing, because now we've entered
the end game, where it is
overpopulation, too much wealth, so too
much inequality,
and so woman are forced to pick the best
possible mate, or not have children at
all.
All right? And here, the situation is
very very dire. North America and Europe
are kind of okay. Why? Because of
immigration.
Because even though their woman are not
having children, they can choose to
import
people for their labor force.
But East Asia is really really screwed,
guys, okay? So, just look at this
region.
Okay. So, China is one, but the worst is
North Korea. Uh sorry, South Korea.
South Korea has the lowest population
uh rate in Sorry, the lowest fertility
rate in the world. They're at at between
0.6 to 0.8. So, they'll probably gone in
50 years' time. It's so bad that when
you go to South Korea, they have signs
outside restaurants that says, "No dogs
and no kids."
They think that kids are problem.
Okay? So,
you look at the these areas,
again, they are poorer, so woman are
forced to have more children in order to
survive.
Okay? But you look at wealthy areas,
well, they'll probably gone in 100
years' time.
And you it's total
total collapse.
The solution that governments are
choosing right now is to import
immigrants.
Okay?
Especially So, these are the trends
right now.
And it's causing a lot of disruption in
society, because guess what, guys?
People don't like outsiders. People
don't like immigrants.
But they don't have a choice in the
matter, because along with the fertility
crisis,
is the aging crisis, where your
population is getting older and older.
Okay?
So,
life The world is not that simple. If
you want to know who will rule the world
in your 100 years' time, just figure out
which society In which society do
wealthy, well-educated woman choose to
have children? And then that society
will rule the world.
Okay? It's that simple, right?
>> [snorts]
>> Well, unfortunately, if you do it that
way,
you get a really really disturbing
answer.
Okay? So, this is
per capita G uh
GDP, okay? So, how much people make.
All right? So, obviously, if you're
zero, you're very poor, and
um if you move to over here, you're very
wealthy, okay? So, the United States
is the wealthiest society in the world,
right? Sure, we can understand that.
Then this is the fertility rate, which
tells us how many children woman have on
average. Okay? So, again, 2.1
is replacement rate, okay? 2.1 is
replacement rate. The United States is
actually below replacement rate, but the
United States doesn't really care,
because they can import immigrants.
Okay?
Um
China is probably around here somewhere
somewhere, okay?
Um
Angola is up here, but it's poor. So,
what this map tells us is a country that
is most likely to be dominant for the
next 50 years is
this country.
Israel.
Okay? It It is the only wealthy,
Western, high-tech society in which
woman choose to have more than two kids.
Okay, this is what game theory teaches
us. And yeah, I know there are people
like, "Yeah, but Israel, it's um it has
9 million people.
And um it's in the middle of a desert.
And everyone hates Israel." I understand
that. Thank you very much, okay?
I understand that.
But if you just analyze how the game
works,
okay? If you just look at it
objectively,
from a game theory perspective, you are
forced to conclude that Israel, right
now, has the major advantage over
everyone else. Now,
it is possible that societies will
change their fertility rate as the
the world changes, okay? But I'm saying
that, given the current state of of
things, Israel, their growth trajectory
trajectory is very very high.
But then the question then is, "Okay,
why is it that Israel,
they are different from everyone else?"
And the answer is
because the world hates them.
Okay? Because they think they are
different from everyone else,
and
they must unite together to survive.
So, in Israel, fertility
is status.
Okay?
If you are a woman and you give birth to
a lot of kids, that means that you love
Israel. That means that you are doing
what you can in this war
for survival.
It means you are a patriot.
Okay?
Um but this has to do with religion.
So,
what the West has done is not only
um has it created dating game where
where women can choose to have kids, but
the Western world has also given up our
religion and embraced materialism.
Right?
So, what is valued
in our world, in the West, it's not
patriotism
or love of family
or religious duty. It's just
how many Instagram followers you have.
It's how many YouTube subscribers you
have. It's how many
how much money you have. Okay? That's
all that matters.
So, given the current state of events,
it's very hard for the Western world and
really for China to survive next for
next 50 years, okay? All right. And I
know like, "Well, China has a billion
people, so even though
um
you know, we're only giving birth to 10
million kids a year, we're still we'll
still be around for a long, long time,
okay?" So, at this rate, by 2100,
China will be at will be at a population
of 600 million. That's still a lot of
people, man.
Um okay.
Here's the problem, though.
Okay. There's a South Korea. Okay, South
Korea is like the worst-case scenario.
And for South Korea, this is actually
the best-case scenario where, "Okay,
given current trends, and let's let's
just pretend that nothing bad happens to
South South Korea. Well, by the year
2100, you'll you'll have a situation
like this where the vast majority of
people are over 65, and you have no
kids, okay?"
That is a zombie society where no one
works, and everyone just
I don't know, walks around the park
every day.
No one works, so the economy has
collapsed.
Okay? So, look look look look at this
trend where we are now in here, okay?
Where where the majority is still a
working population, which is good. You
need that for the economy. But by the
time you hit 2040,
okay, you've got this huge dependency
and a Korean population, okay? You you
you guys see this? Where we are?
In um okay, so we're 2020, right? Okay.
All right, so it's still not too bad.
But by the time you hit 2040, look at
this.
Okay? Look at this Look at this where
you have actually no kids, and then you
have lots and lots of retirees.
Okay?
And then by the time you hit 2060, oh my
god.
Right?
Your population your working population
has decreased by half by 50%.
All right?
So,
if things are stay the same, if nothing
happens,
South Korea will be will be dead in I
don't know, by
150, okay? Best-case scenario.
But what we know from history is that
societies do not die naturally.
Eventually, South Korea will be forced
into wars, into economic crises. So,
this trend will just increase. And so,
if North Korea got got past 2080, I'd be
very surprised, okay? I'd be surprised
by 2040
South Korea were to face collapse as a
nation-state.
Okay? Because you need these people to
work, but guess what? You also need them
to fight wars. So, if North Korea ever
threatens South Korea,
most of your
adult population will be dead.
Okay?
So, South Korea can't fight a war now.
The prospects for South Korea is utterly
hopeless. There's nothing South Korea
can do about this
because
South Korea is extremely materialistic
society where
the only way only way only way to get
ahead is by making a lot of money, okay?
And if you were a middle-class person in
South Korea, it makes no sense for you
to have three kids. It makes sense for
you to have one kid and put all your
resources into this one kid in the hopes
that he passes the college examination,
gets into a good university, and then
gets a good job at Samsung, which is the
only company in South Korea, okay?
Samsung.
All right, so the situation is pretty
dire in South Korea.
All right.
Okay, that's it for
today. Any questions, guys, about what
we've learned?
Okay.
Yeah. Speaking of Mike, please.
>> So so for the last graph that uh we
talked about Israel, and I've noticed
that the Saudi Arabia that is also like
uh at uh half
not bad
GDP per capita and fertility rates. So,
but for Saudi Arabia, maybe I'm wrong
like uh stereotypically that they didn't
receive uh much hate as Israel did. So,
so why did they like at the similar
position as Israel? Okay.
That's actually a really good question.
>> Okay. All right.
So,
South Saudi Arabia, as you see from this
map, has it's a very wealthy society.
Um and families have about four kids on
on average. All right, so South Saudi
Arabia it it's actually an outlier. And
the reason why is that it gets all its
money from oil oil revenues, okay? So,
it sells its oil around the world. What
what does it do?
It creates a welfare state using this
oil.
Um so, you're incentivized to have
um
many children as possible because the
government will pay for it. Free
schooling, free health care, free
housing, and then a guaranteed job.
So, it's basically like socialism.
Uh it's also a Muslim country, so you
have this religious duty imperative to
have have as many children as possible.
Okay? But the problem with Saudi Arabia
is the idea of human capital.
Where it is not really a moral society
in which people are well-educated, and
they're contributing to the to the
economy, okay? Saudi Arabia just gets
just gets all its money from oil, and
that's it. It's trying to grow ter-
terrorism. It's trying to develop its uh
human capital.
But it doesn't really work, okay? So, so
you're right in that Saudi Arabia
um it is
uh it seems to be doing well, but it's
not really, okay?
Um but also like people will argue about
Israel as well. We're like, "Well,
Israel gets all its money from the
United States, and it's the American
military that supports Israel."
Um that's true to a certain extent, but
I would argue that if you actually go to
Israel, you will see that it's an open,
dynamic society in which you're allowed
to ask questions, which you're allowed
to criticize the government,
uh in which you are given a lots of
opportunities for social mobility, okay?
So, Israel has democracy.
It has uh innovation, okay? It has
um
um technology.
Okay? And Saudi Arabia doesn't have
these things. If you want to be a really
strong nation, then you need innovation,
you need openness, you need you need
technology, okay? It's also um really
highly educated.
All right? Okay, does that make sense?
Okay, so Saudi Arabia is really an
outlier here.
All right, but the problem is what
happens if
uh Saudi Saudi Arabia runs out of oil,
right? Or there's a war in the Middle
East. Then Saudi Arabia is kind of
screwed.
All right.
All right. But you can also argue, "No,
well, you know, Saudi Arabia it has a
lot of money, and maybe okay." So, so
game theory doesn't give us the answers.
Game theory we it just gives us a guide
to ask questions and do research, okay?
Does that make sense?
Uh yeah. Um I have a question about
Uh I have a question about
like when is this data? It's it's rows
about 2009, right? So, how about now?
Did it change a lot? Or like is there
anything changed?
Um Okay. Okay, yeah.
So, you asked you asked about the
sourcing of the data.
Okay? And you're right in that there
there will be fluctuation, okay?
But the um
But this is 2024, okay? 2024,
and this is
Israel right here.
Okay?
All right. So, if it's red, it's above
replacement.
All right. And if you just Google
Israel population fertility rate,
Israel is the only wealthy nation in the
world that has an above-replacement
fertility rate, okay?
All right.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay? [clears throat]
Any any more questions, guys?
All right, great. So, I will see you
guys next class.